and uh
welcome to our third talk of the day
uh sorry we're starting hi
uh welcome to the first talk of the day
uh we are we are very very fortunate to
have uh john kleinberg like giving a
talk
uh at our workshop uh john is truly
somebody who needs no introduction he's
like a world expert like uh in both
algorithms uh algorithm design and
network science uh he's written a
seminal book and he's the recipient of
many many prizes including the
famous nevada prize
so we are truly fortunate to have him
give a talk and today he'll be talking
about the challenge of understanding
what users want
thank you so much john and uh the floor
is yours
okay uh thanks thanks very much for the
invitation to take part in the workshop
and
uh sorry that i'm not able to be there
in person but i hope to be uh
out of berkeley at some point in the in
the future in the near future so um and
to see many people out there
um okay and i'm assuming the sound and
everything is still working okay is that
is that good
all right
um great
okay so
yeah so what i wanted to talk about
today was some work that um
uh senthil melanothen and minish rajvon
and i have been doing uh over the past
uh
two years or so um thinking about um
some
questions related to
modeling user behavior on social media a
kind of problem that uh
um i've certainly been thinking about
for a long time but
with a particular focus on sort of
things you know that we see happening uh
at the moment on you know on large
social media sites on youtube on
facebook on
twitter and
to sort of think about the communication
problem in effect that's happening in
which um
it feels as though users are you know or
on these sites all of us are on these
sites platforms are trying to sort of
optimize for their experience but
somehow you know there's sort of this
intuition that a lot of people express
that you know that you often read in in
the news media that some of the more
platforms optimize
the less happy users seem to get with
the experience right it feels like
there's something working across
purposes here
and so what what might that be and so i
want to start with you know sort of how
we often think about social media when
we go to uh think about models of this
which is you know to emphasize the sort
of social and social media to think
about this is a place where we go to
find out what people think about things
right we go online because we're curious
what people have to say about topics
that we've seen going on we want to you
know read news we want to read people's
reactions to news and you know and so we
you know often come across you know
headlines like this one which i
screenshotted in spring of 2016 while
the uh 2016 democratic primary was uh
going on um it was on this blog called
thepeoplesview.net which i don't even
know how i ended up at since i don't
think i've read it before or since um
and it's an open letter to matt tybee of
rolling stone magazine it's a brilliant
response from a millennial to matt
tybee's displeasure over rolling stones
endorsement of hillary clinton and so
this is a kind of thing you find on
social media i screenshotted this one
back in spring of 2016 because i felt
like
there was something sort of deliciously
complicated about this um and the reason
why it feels delicious and complicated
is that
this is not a story about hillary
clinton uh it's not even a story about
rolling stones endorsement of hillary
clinton no it's actually
maybe it's about matt tybee's
displeasure over rolling stones
endorsement hillary clinton but actually
it's not even that it's really this
brilliant response that a millennial
apparently had to matt tybee's uh
displeasure and think how effortlessly
you know your brain maps the cast of
characters in that one sentence right
this is very much what we do when we go
on to social media right there's hillary
clinton this rolling stone matt tybee
had an opinion about rolling stone the
millennial had a response you know had a
opinion about what matt type he said but
of course you're not hearing from the
millennial that's not what you're doing
you're hearing from the peoplesview.net
you know and
we we do this effortlessly right the
reason why opinion dynamics on the
internet feels complicated is because it
is genuinely complicated right to even
map out this one sentence involves me
building a little network diagram of
course you're not reading the people you
can talk that you're listening to me
give a talk about this thing i read in
the peoplesview.net right so now to the
extent that you have an opinion on all
of this you're even more steps removed
from what's going on here right so this
is something that we know about about
media
um
namely that it's not just about the
content that we read there but it's
about the other people both the
interactions and also the conflicts
between other people right so we've
known this for a long time um at a
workshop uh not unlike uh
not unlike
this this one that i went to at uh
columbia in 2004 although unlike this
one it did not have a virtual component
um i
had a series of really fascinating
conversations i felt very fortunate to
meet
el ella who katz one of the early
scholars of mass communication from the
middle of the 20th century uh and
we interested in conversation because at
ellahu katz with his mentor paul
plazersfeld one of the founders of the
study of mass communication they written
this book personal influence in 1955 in
which they were trying to make sense of
the effect of disruptive technological
change on the political process for them
disruptive technological change was you
know tv and the radio uh and in 2004
um
you know i was looking at blogging and i
was thinking about what i was convinced
most surely was going to be the most
contentious u.s presidential election
that we were ever going to see the bush
versus kerry election of 2004 and we
were discussing you know the comparisons
and the contrast between the kind of
mass communication that they you know
that they thought about in the 1950s and
the kind of things that we were seeing
with with blogging in 2004 and in a way
starting in 2004 you know moving through
blogging through early social media
through online video sharing um
you know through all of these things you
know i think you know we've seen this
kind of road map of research get mapped
out right in which we formulate that
work on social media in terms of
interactions and conflicts between
people through things like the diffusion
of innovation
uh through polarization through
misinformation
through recent work on you know the
search for radicalization pathways and
social media right this idea that the
conflict is taking place uh between
people
um i say this to kind of frame you know
how i arrived at the problems i'm going
to be talking about
today because in a way what what sort of
intrigued sendel and manish and me as we
began thinking about you know the state
of social media and what we might try to
say about it in in the early 2000s early
2020 um you know looking both at our own
experience also talking to people at you
know the
companies that were you know working on
these things as we all know people at
those companies
how it was not just about
the interactions and the conflicts uh
between
distinct people
in a way
in order to really think about social
media we have to think about a second
source of conflicts the way in which
social media creates conflicts within
each of us individually right the way in
which it actually
generates internal conflict and then
somehow actually derives a lot of
its complexity from how that internal
conflict plays out as we uh
as we consume social media what do i
mean by internal conflict like here it's
obvious what conflict between people is
right we see arguments on social media
what do we mean by internal conflict and
i mean things that you of course will
also recognize from you know a whole set
of parallel news headlines right in
which for example you know we spend long
periods of time during the day
you know doom scrolling through news
about covid and news about new variants
knowing it's making us
nervous and unhappy uh but somehow
returning to do it and somehow not able
to stop right we find people you know
not only
you know seeking to leave social media
even even people are very active right
people often get more and more active on
a platform and then suddenly go sort of
cold turkey right they suddenly
announced that's it i'm stopping as of
today right people even seek out advice
apparently from you know people with
titles like professional internet
twitter someone who advises how to quit
the internet um you know and we see sort
of you know
questions thrown out to the reddit
community like how do i spend less time
on youtube and if there weren't this
growing line of research on these kinds
of questions you you might think this
was a remarkably easy question the way
to spend less time on youtube is to not
go to youtube right and that tends to
you would think solve the problem but of
course we know it's much much more
right and so if i think about sort of
you know this growing line of work over
the last uh few years that's happening
in in the hci community
you know in uh
in in the online social media community
in
uh empirical
economics in the theory of mass
communication
people looking at you know
this sort of constellation of things
right which in some cases you could
think of as
digital addiction but often it's it's
it's sort of somewhere you know milder
than you know you might call
addiction but sort of you know
over consumption regretful use of the
platform right sort of the sense in
which that we spend more time than we
want to right we we go online but we
don't actually feel like we want to be
there in a way there's yet another
diagram going on right the the facebook
quitting advice from a professional
internet twitter is itself a little
complicated story to think right it's
about the part of you that wants to use
facebook
and the conflict that has with the part
of you that wants to override this urge
to use facebook and in some sense the
professional internet quitter is sort of
trying to help one side of you in its
struggle against the other side right
they're sort of they're they're picking
sides in a conflict but that conflict is
happening within yourself right and
that's what this you know this growing
volume of research on over consumption
of social media is thinking about
and so
as people you know began looking at you
know more and more empirical work in
this direction right so you know looking
at experiments for example in which we
pay people not to use social media and
then we measure their happiness
afterwards people in which we you know
introduce um commitment devices right we
say what are some design features i
might introduce that you know whereby
you can set timers and make sure that
you don't spend more time than you want
on this on these platforms
um
it
we thought it would be interesting to
think about what you know what might a
model of this conflict look like right
in the same way we have models for
conflicts between people and social
networks what might a model this
internal conflict look like and for that
um you know among the three of us handle
miniature nice cental certainly has had
by far the most practice thinking about
some of these uh you know behavioral
inte you know these behavioral biases
these internal conflicts and one of the
sort of key starting points is this you
know
theme that's now become you know sort of
uh fundamental to how people think about
this in behavioral sciences the
distinction between want and should
right so this is the distinction between
want and should um you know we see it
for example in you know food consumption
to draw an analogy with media
consumption that you know you could be
at you know a party a reception uh a
dinner and you know in front of you is a
bowl of salad and a bowl of potato chips
and one part of you sort of knows which
one you should be eating and a different
part of you perhaps is just you know
unreasonably tempted by
the
potato chips and you know and this is
sort of in you know star contrast the uh
the conflicts that that one sees and of
course you know you also see this
um you know not just with food but to go
back to our motivating example of media
um people also looked at empirical
research on want versus should in
consumption of media right so you were
trying to decide what movie to watch and
you could watch you know an avengers
movie
um you know something loud and noisy
which is sort of immediately accessible
you know where you could watch you know
a thought-provoking documentary like
this one on the helvetica font right in
which they point out that the cast of
characters are the letters of the
alphabets that you're all familiar with
and the movies about helvetica um right
so this is a should movie it would be
good for you
but you'd have to actually decide to
pick this one you know rather than
another one you know and this one
advertises that you can start watching
immediately with your public library
card or university login i suppose on
the assumption that the only people who
are conceivably going to watch this
or go to a university so these are the
kinds of
things people think about when they
think about distinction wants and should
i and i picked these two examples
because actually each of them has been
the subject of you know quite
interesting not just lab studies but
actually
um
field work right empirical evidence that
people
um for example consume want goods more
in you know in the more immediate term
and they consume should goods over the
uh um
longer term right so for example uh you
know the first uh
i'll mention two studies here both by
this uh
uh
trio katie milkman todd rodgers and max
baserman um so for food that you know
they looked at online grocery orders
placed by the same households
where the delivery dates for different
orders you know were further out you
know sometimes you wanted the groceries
later that day or the next day sometimes
you want them three days or four days in
advance
and you know
what they found was actually this you
know this
very strong uh regularity that when the
date by which you were requesting the
groceries was further in the future they
contained more should items you know
more things like salad and when you were
asking for things that were going to be
arriving sooner they contain more want
goods right more like potato chips
similarly um
in the mail-order
dvd era right so when people actually
you know
in things like the early days of netflix
when you went and requested uh movies to
come by mail on dvd and then you played
them then you mailed them back and you
maintained your netflix queue um they
looked at what you might call inversions
right where the same household orders
movie a before movie b
but they return movie b before movie a
right so there's kind of a
lifo kind of thing going on in the
language computer science right a comes
in before b but b goes back up and in
those inversions um those were
characterized by a
significantly increased likelihood that
the movie that came in and went back out
faster was a want movie and a was a
should movie right that the documentary
sort of sat around because when the
when when the want movie came in it it
literally jumped the queue and and you
watched it first okay
um and actually
um people have observed that this
actually
the for example the netflix prize
competition in which people
competed to improve netflix's uh movie
recommendations actually
unfolded right around the time that
netflix was migrating from a mail order
company to a instant streaming company
over the internet because the bandwidth
around that area had reached the point
where you know you could actually stream
to the home reliably
and as a result
a lot of the algorithms trained on on
the mail order data
weren't actually very good in the
streaming world because the mail order
data was really a should kind of world
right it's things that you're like i bet
in two days i'm gonna want to watch a
movie about the font helvetica
and you move to a streaming world where
you can watch anything you want right
now and suddenly
the want side takes over right and so as
well models trained in a mail order
world there's no reason to believe that
they're necessarily going to be so good
in a in a instant streaming world
and so all of this bil these these field
studies in turn build on you know
several lines of work in uh
in behavioral
economics um
on time and consistency
on the notion of sophistication right
the idea that you're aware of this
conflict and so although that doesn't
mean you can solve the conflict you you
can at least you know take steps to try
addressing it right you can sort of you
know position yourself near the salad
you can
um you know order things that you think
are gonna be good for in the long run
and so forth um and relates the idea of
sophistication right the idea that
sophistication is the ability to reflect
on your inactions these so-called
multiple self models in which you know
which try to actually you know discuss
that there is a conflict going on
between sort of two sides
okay
so
why is this interesting for us if we're
trying to build models of social media
consumption well because obviously
you know as these last few examples
suggest you know basic question
platforms must answer is what do users
want what are they interested in right
what movie is it that you're going to
want to see what is it you want to see
now was it you would want to order for
two days from now
and
write an enormous amount of data
analysis obviously this is all uh
familiar to all of us that enrollment
data analysis enormous amount of a b
testing experimentation goes into trying
to determine the answers to these
questions
and
a fundamental
assumption
in all of this is you know to
draw on one more term from the
behavioral science literature the
principle of revealed preference right
the principle of revealed preference
says people choose what they want
so
choice reveals preference
right that i could ask you what you
think you might want but it's hard to
find a substitute for seeing what you
actually want in the moment i mean
literally that's what you wanted right
um and in a way
although you know the phrase revealed
preference doesn't always show up on
page one of textbooks about recommender
systems or
you know books on analyzing
digital traces on on online platforms
fundamentally
the fact that
studying digital trace data is so
powerful is a statement about a belief
in revealed reference we are seeing
people's actual choices we're going to
train models for them and this is
essential for online platforms to
function right our point here is not to
somehow
um suggest that you know we should not
be looking at all of this data
our point though is that you know this
data
i think we're increasingly coming to
appreciate
is complicated to make sense of
um and part of that reason
is because of you know all of the
limitations of revealed reference that
you know that these long lines of work
and behavioral science have pointed out
right the limitations of revealed
preference are that in fact you know you
have internal conflicts so i'm seeing
what part of one side of you want to do
but i'm not necessarily getting an
actual snapshot of your entire set of
preferences and how they resolved or
failed to resolve the conflict that was
going on inside you right so you know in
particular
you know if we to continue pivoting back
and forth between food and media um you
know you're at a party and you you know
really fast eat all the potato chips in
the bowl
now you know part of you is sort of
hoping the host refills the bowl so
there'll be more potato chips but part
of you would love it if the host takes
the empty bowl back to the kitchen and
doesn't bring it back out because then
you'll be safe from eating any more
potato chips right but if someone were
just looking at your behavioral trace
data you know it would be
you would have to actually sort of think
hard to remember not to simply say they
finished a bowl of chips therefore they
like chips therefore we should provide
more chips right and the question that
we started from is you know to think
about the way in which user models
actually work you know and to say is
this fundamentally what's happening
online you know is it that i watch you
consume a lot of media of a certain type
i decide you must like this kind of
media and i show you a whole bunch more
right suddenly your youtube landing
homepage is filled with that kind of
that kind of uh video because you
watched a bunch of it right is that like
the bowl of chips
um and if it isn't to what extent is it
not
okay that's the uh
so now of course
whether you get the right conclusions
from revealed preference sort of depends
on what is being chosen right so you can
imagine situations where it would make
sense for your host to refill the salad
bowl
uh but for them to take away the empty
chips bowl
right it could be that the kind of food
you're consuming
uh might matter and that surely must be
true of online platforms as well right
that it's not so much
is this revealed preference strategy the
right idea or the wrong idea but rather
when is it the right idea right when
does it make sense to apply revealed
preference to trace data and when does
it not and
how can we possibly tell apart those two
kinds of
of situations right
okay
now
i'm gonna start moving toward
building this this this model and we
think of it much more as a model of
media consumption than food consumption
because the analogy
between the two while
very useful to keep in mind is certainly
not perfect right it's not just that
there's a fixed you know inventory of
food and platforms simply need to figure
out what's what
the online world gives us just
infinitely more diversity of content
infinitely more flexibility of design
right it's really much more when you're
on youtube or facebook that you're in
a billion product grocery store the
shelves are constantly reconfiguring and
new foods are constantly being
bioengineered in response to your
consumption
right the the content is changing
non-stop and there is this this
feed feedback loop right and this is not
to suggest that there isn't a food
industry that is constantly innovating
and that you know it is certainly the
case that today's potato chips are
different from the payout ships of five
or ten years ago but the cycle time is
much slower right it's not happening
sort of as you're consuming whereas in
the online world it's literally
happening
on a cycle time that's about the same
speed as the rate at which you're able
to consume
okay and that
somehow makes this you know even more
complicated so let's talk about a
model okay and so my
my goals here are sort of you know you
know on the one hand modest on the one
hand sort of aspirational right um
they're aspirational in a sense that you
know we think this is something that's
interesting to try building models of
and it seems like there's really a lot
of space to explore here at the same
time our goals are somewhat modest you
know in this talk and in the in this
paper the talk is based on in that you
know
we want to sort of see what a model like
this would look like and so we're going
to try to do things very simply um we're
going to sort of make simple decisions
when we can and in particular in this
talk especially i'm going to sort of
pick things that i can sort of work
through in real time you know just so
that you can sort of uh see how some of
these work so the paper has you know
some more complex versions of what i'll
talk about here um but it it only really
in a sentence from our view seems to
scratch the surface of what's going on
okay
so building a model of this
so in the spirit of trying to sort of
have all the ingredients be as simple as
possible because as we'll see
interesting things happen even then um
let's imagine you know there's a user
and they're consuming a
linear content feed right so they are
working their way through a twitter
timeline
through their facebook news feed through
a playlist on youtube right something
where the real the main decision right
now is do you continue to the next item
or do you not right at what point do you
stop scrolling and go
do something else um
toward the end of the talk i'll suggest
you know what this would look like if
for example there were a branching
component of this like you know there's
a youtube sidebar with like here are the
10 options for what to watch next um
i'll come back to that but
a bunch of things happen even in this
world where i'm simply you know working
my way through
you know through
things on my twitter timeline basically
trying to decide whether to eat the next
potato chip
okay and in the spirit of these multiple
self models the user has two sets of
preferences system one and system two
now the term system one system two gets
used a lot across
um economics and behavioral sciences um
we mean it for something extremely
specific here right so we don't need
necessarily to
bring in all of the
different theoretical infrastructure
that's been built around these two terms
um
we're simply thinking of two competing
sets of preferences that exist within
the same
individual the the user in this case
and in particular
um
you know system one is numbered one
because it's it acts faster right so
system one is the impulsive one it acts
first and particularly it acts before
you know system two is able to sort of
get up and start doing things um
and whereas system two is gonna be the
sort of slower moving more planning
oriented uh set of preferences
okay so we're looking at the sequence of
items in your
in your feed or your timeline um you
know number t equals zero one two and so
forth item t is going to produce a
utility u sub t for system one which is
drawn from some distribution id from
distribution u again almost everything i
say is some decision to make the model
simple so that we can see what happens
and obviously all of these we come back
to
okay
so
system one really just cares do i want
to eat the next chip or not is it gonna
give me positive utility right so system
one is very focused on the distinction
between you know positive utility and
negative utility and so if u sub t is
positive uh it will
it's enjoying the current item number t
it will continue on t plus one
and let's say you know this is some
distribution has some probability of
being positive and let's say it's
positive probability alright so p is an
important term it is the probability
that system one is engaged by what it's
doing right now and therefore remains in
control to go consume the next thing
now if u sub t is less or equal to zero
then system one
temporarily is not engaged right we
might get engaged by the next thing
comes along but
it's not engaged and so there's a window
for system two right it hands off
control to system two because it doesn't
wanna act right now
so let's ask okay system two the slower
one to rouse uh what does it do
all right so system two uses
long range planning um and so when it
wakes up at step t because system one is
bored
it looks out ahead across this you know
feed of content stretching off to
infinity
um
what does it know it knows its utility
for the current um
the current item now it doesn't
necessarily so system one had utility u
sub t but system two has different
preferences so it has utility v sub t
drawn id from some distribution script v
with mean v bar
and let's remember mean v bar that's
another important parameter
because that's the average utility that
you get from consuming an item you being
system two i'll also say that in this
whole narration we're going to sort of
implicitly take the side of system two
right all of us are kind of system two
kind of trapped along for the ride as
system one risks over consuming uh you
know this website that we're on but
we're sort of interested in ultimately
you know it's system two that's gonna
look retrospectively on this experience
and decide what it thinks and so we're
interested in system two's utility in
the in the long run
okay
so now system two could leave the site
right it could decide not to consume and
get v sub t if it leaves at every step
it has an outside option of capital w
okay so imagine there's a cloud floating
over every one of these not just this
one because at any moment
when system two is in control it can
leave but it has to be in control to
decide to move
okay and finally these items are the
numbers are grayed out because it knows
the value of vt it only knows that these
are drawn from this distribution v
okay and that is the planning problem it
faces right should i continue on
um knowing that i'm drawing from this
distribution giving up this outside
option
or should i not okay
um and remember it it sort of it
receives control in the middle of item t
system one has decided it's boarded
powers down hands things off to system
two system two's already gotten the
value vt because it's in the middle of
consuming this it's really about whether
to go on and down this unknown stream
okay
now as stated there's something sort of
missing from this model that we have to
kind of
settle which is
if
v but which is some kind of
principle of diminishing returns has to
come here because
v bar
well okay if v bar is less than
w then
system two has no interest in being on
this platform because it can get it
would be happier with it outside option
than with the expected value of what
it's going to consume next so the
question gets interesting when v bar is
greater than w
but if v bar is greater than w we have
to ask what is it that's causing system
two to ever want to leave right without
some kind of attenuation of this
you know because these are being drawn
id
um every step looks better the system
two uh than leaving and getting the
outside option because v is bigger than
w
so any model is going to have to capture
the fact that system two will eventually
want to leave right imagine there were
no system one right we can make system
one go away by assuming we're in the
special case where p equals zero
remember p is the probability that
system one is engaged
we can always say let's imagine p equals
zero and then we just have a pure system
two problem right an agent that can plan
ahead you know and has a single set of
preferences
um why would it ever want to leave if e
bar is bigger than w well it has to be
one of two things right i mean we all
know that we do eventually sorry john
but yep certain thing but i think a
question
sort of interruption i was just trying
can we go in the previous slide
yeah
a little bit i was trying like to too
much the
you know the structural
discussion that we have here with the
discussion about the chips and the salad
what is the intuition behind the fact
that i know the distribution of the
future items
i mean in in the real life uh
setting somehow that yeah what is the
intuition about the module
how are you
know so i guess i can say i'm thinking
about it which is
we're imagining this is sort of system
two is living is operating in a
relatively homogeneous world like it's
it's it's in the middle of its say news
feed or timeline right and so
it has some expectation of like what is
the sort of
you know
what is the distribution of reward it
gets from the next thing it's going to
read as it scrolls through facebook um
you're right it's been on system two has
been on facebook a lot it's seen a lot
of things and so it has some
some picture of the distribution i mean
we could question the independence
assumption obviously we could so
obviously i id is this implication but
in order to engage in this planning
activity
system two needs some presumption of
what it's going to encounter if it stays
on the site and so i think that's the
right so this is not system two in a
sort of unbounded world where anything
could happen next it's system two design
where they keep scrolling in its
timeline
um but having right
having said that of course the future is
unknown right this distribution could
have enormous variance if you wanted
right something you know something you
read next could be wonderful somebody
read next could be terrible that's
that's fine but it's drawn from your
understanding of what you're going to
encounter next to your timeline
is this parameter free i mean
do i know the parameters of the
distributions or i mean i can accept
that distribution
could have a bounded the variance or
something like that but do i know these
parameters uh
as the designer
as a player sorry well there's the
platform designer and there's the user
right currently all this is all taking
place
this is the user right
um now the platform designer has a whole
separate problem the platform designer
sees clicks right they have a big
problem their hands right and that
that's what we would like to get to
right now we're just talking about you
scrolling through your facebook news
feed you have a sense of what you tend
to find in your facebook newsfeed right
you have some sense of like what
what you tend to encounter next as you
keep scrolling the question of what the
platform designer knows right
is is a huge question because the
platform designer basically sees someone
just clicking you know they keep
scrolling at some point they stop
and that's an extremely
limited signal to try drawing
conclusions from so yeah so we'll we'll
come back to that one but right now
we're just talking about the planning
problem that the user is facing
as go through this
um happy to talk more afterwards also
um
so
right so at some point
the user system 2 is going to want to
leave
and so that's either going to happen
because they receive diminishing returns
from the content or because the outside
the value of the outside option is
increasing over over time right as in
there's v bar and there's w and one
either one's going down and one was
going up but they have to cross each
other somehow um we've explored a number
of ways of
doing this and since they lead to
similar things with different levels of
sort of complexity for purposes of doing
this real time in the talk i'm going to
go with one of the sort of simpler
formulations that we've used um which is
let's imagine that um
system two
knows that essentially
it's going to remain interested in each
step independently with probably q right
so as it goes independently probably q
it's going to remain interested step by
step
and right so it's notionally flipping a
point of bias queue when that coin comes
up tails it it feels satisfied it feels
satiated it's done and it's going to
receive no further utility from being on
the site right so system two's in
interest undergoes a single on off
transition
which is sort of memoryless starting
here right it's going to continue to be
interested step by step with probably q
independently and so it knows that the
probability will be interested t steps
from now is q
okay and this is one way to model the
idea that system two is getting
diminishing
value from each new thing it consumes
right the value it expects to be able to
be getting uh t steps in the future is q
to the t
okay
um all right and there are a number we
could also have deterministic
attenuation of the value we could have
rising value
of
w fundamentally these tend to give
similar things
okay so this this probably q is also an
important thing right this is
you know in a world of system two and
control say imagine p equals zero
this is sort of the probability that
you know the sort of longevity of this
content which is different from the
value of this content right we can think
of things that have instantaneous
big value that you you know only might
want to continue for one step right
that's high v bar
low q
um you could also imagine things that
have you know medium v bar high q right
so a kind of slow acquisition of utility
right you know
you can even imagine you know
conversations it can be like this right
you can have a conversation that you
know you meet someone in the hall it's
very animated it's you know high v bar
um but you know you also kind of the
correct length in your mind for this
conversation is two minutes you're
passing the hall you also imagine the
kind of long conversation that's
enjoyable with you know medium vbar uh
high value right so the point is there
are somehow three properties of the
content
and we seem to need all of these right
it sort of feels to us like the sort of
small step we were able to think of
there is the value per item which for
system two is
net value v bar minus w there's this
thing we'll call the spam which is the
probability of system two remains
interest prime which is the longevity of
the content right some things you sort
of
expect to be doing for a long time and
getting interest some things you're
doing briefly and then this term which
we you know uh
uh took from the behavioral science work
moorishness right certain items are very
moorish meaning you just impulsively
want more right potato chips are moorish
um and that's the probability p
that system one is in control when
consuming a piece of content right you
know in the sort of
dire world where p equals one it would
mean you are literally trapped because
system one just wants to keep going
forever
okay so these these three things right
the value of the content the span for
system two and the and the margins and
we're interested in
um
system two's utility for all of this
okay
so let's actually think about
a session that this user
you know experiences on this platform
right and again the platform has created
whatever it created
so far the platform is somewhere in the
background they have no agency in the
story right now this is about the user
in their decisions you know knowing what
they know about their twitter timeline
their facebook news feed um what does a
session look like from their perspective
right because in a way
and let's talk about you know the sort
of role system two at the entry point
right the the question of do i want to
go on this platform
to today right do i feel like opening up
facebook right now that's a system
typically um and we'll actually come
back to this point is typically a system
two decision right you actually have to
decide i'm going to open up facebook
right there isn't anything impulsively
tempting with this exact moment you have
to actually make that decision and so
system two actually has a big decision
at the outset which is what is my
expected utility from opening up
facebook right now knowing everything's
gonna happen i'm gonna start reading
system two system one's gonna wake up
and drag me along for a while i'll get
back in control i'll make some decisions
you know at some point i'll leave and
i'll acquire some utility and it's
traded off against what i could have
been doing
not on facebook which is this outside
option w
okay so a session fundamentally you know
looks like this it sort of has two
phases and the two the boundary between
the phases is determined by when system
two is satiated right when they have
reached the point they're like i have
now consumed all the utility i'm gonna
consume
right so
satiation for system two remember is
you know it's flipping a coin of bias q
and at some point you know this on off
the screen on off switch happens and it
now has decided it is done it wants to
stop and so the expected length of this
first phase is one over one minus q
during which system two is acquiring
value from whatever it it it consumes um
once that transition happens system two
would like to leave
um does it get to leave well not
immediately because the very next thing
coming up might uh impulsively excite
system one who therefore stays
and system one will keep staying as long
as it's in control
right and so system one wanting to
continue well
that's a coin flip with bias p
uh which is continued independently
going forward um so that has expected
length p over one minus p the one versus
the p is because it's possible that
system like system two decided to go
onto facebook so they're going to see
the first thing there was system one
might be bore like
we might have the happy coincidence that
when system two wants to leave system
one happens to not engage that moment
and then the length of this phase is
actually zero
okay so phase one system two is
collecting v bar minus w utility per
step
over one over one minus q steps and so
the expected utility from phase one is v
bar minus w over one minus q
in phase two
system two has now lost interest and so
it's now collecting minus w utility per
step right it's experiencing pure
opportunity cost for every step it takes
because it gets zero utility it's
getting minus w for every time it's here
but it has to stay there as long as
system one continues to be interested
and that expected planes is uh p or
minus p right and this in a way is sort
of describing you know a sort of
you know a kind of
in technical cartoon form you know what
we might imagine as a session in which
you over consume right you consume a
little more than you want you have a
period of regretful use at the end in
which you're there you're getting
utility for a while and at some point
you would like you know you're like i
really should be going but somehow you
can't pull yourself away right and
that's being personified here is this
conflict with system one which we should
remember system one is also you
right
okay
um
so
that says system two's utility is a
random variable s
and the random variable s is the value
it gets from this first phase v bar
minus w one minus q minus the
opportunity cost it loses from having to
stay through the second phase pw or an
ice cream and it's the max of this with
zero because system two is one that
chose to go on the platform in the first
place so if if we're going if it knew
we're going to get negative expect
utility it would not go on the platform
a key point actually right it says if
the platform is providing
negative expected utility
you know
system two has the ability to not go
right on again once you're on the
platform system one might drag you along
and burn off some of the utility you've
you've acquired and those are two
different things
okay and then the length of the session
right the session length
yep
i should so i mean that last point is
interesting because we were talking
about how i'm not on tick tock
because i i'm afraid i would be on tick
tock but can the can the system two
interrupt prematurely and say
i think system one's gonna take over
soon and i think this is gonna end soon
or they don't have the knowledge or
foresight to do that
they do have knowledge force they do
that actually so this is a place where
other models we have which won't fit
into this talk uh
get at this point so if i go back here
there's
the reason why this sort of works well
to kind of all of us we can do real-time
calculations with it is that this
process is memoryless so every time
system two wakes up because it's this id
coin flip right it's this geometric
distribution
it's it looks just the same as when it
first started in a world where i was
deterministically satiating right so
imagine a world where like the utility
at
t steps in is deterministically like q
to the t times v right so i'm actually
deterministically losing utility as i go
that's a different world because then
actually the optimal policy for system
two is to stop slightly early
it's like i'm still enjoying this
but the next time i'm likely to wake up
the next time system one's like they
hand control over to me uh i'm gonna
have lost more utility than i've gained
and so i should leave now like i should
sort of leave myself wanting a bit more
is actually a good idea
um and so in the world of deterministic
attenuation you actually get that
reasoning and it's actually not
particularly harder than this to work
out but yeah it seemed but that's the
difference between the men right and so
it's almost again it's crucial to
remember
these are both you right but in a world
where we personify these as different
people this is the story of like you
know
system two realizes i'm still enjoying
the party probably for another few
minutes but i should leave now and i
should you know convince my friend i
came with system one to also leave
because the danger is once system one
gets dragged into a bunch of
conversations i have to stay at the
party longer than i want to right yeah
is that
um
okay and so the session length is a
random variable that's an easy one in
this memory of this model it's one over
one minus q plus p of one minus p
right and so this is somehow you know
this pair of equations
is actually
um
kind of useful to look at in contrast
let me put them here in contrast right
because they both have a first term that
has a denominator one one minus q and a
second term has a dominator one minus p
and
so if we think of
e of s's utility how much i
value the experience
e of t is the length of time i spent on
the platform right so let's start let's
start kind of bringing the platform's
perspective on this right the platform
has a hard time figuring out
what is your utility we'll come back to
that the platform does send you surveys
you know how are you enjoying your
youtube experience today right how is
facebook working out for you today did
you accomplish what you wanted to today
on twitter um but those surveys are rare
right they're an incredibly narrow
signal compared to the voluminous data
that they're getting from clicks but the
voluminous data they're getting from
click is about usage
right and so
you know what's in your mind is utility
but what's observable much more easily
observable is
simply the temporal measure right which
we can think of as some simple proxy for
engagement right obviously real
engagement measures would include things
like you know how much did you click the
like button how much did you comment
when you were there uh how many seconds
did you watch into the little video
clips all that's true but you know
for keeping the model simple let's
imagine that you know the engagement
signal here is length of time spend on
classes
so utility which is what the user cares
about engagement which is what the
platform can observe they agree in this
first term right they're both
monotonically increasing in them where
they disagree is in the second term
where it's negative for utility and
positive for engagement
right which makes sense right system one
is the wedge that's sort of driving the
difference between utility and
engagement
um
okay and so what this is telling us is
that you know when p is zero
then utility is growing monotonically
with engagement so measuring engagement
is actually a good proxy for utility
right in a world without internal
conflict in the users where the user
could plan perfectly right and there
were no potato chips then in fact the
strategy the platform might have to
let's try to increase engagement
right we've we're changing our content
around to increase engagement would be a
good strategy because as engagement goes
up
uh utility goes up
but
if p might range over a large set of
possible values then we're not sure long
sessions could be a sign of you know
high q high utility you know or it could
be a sign of high value to p which would
actually have a negative effect on
utility and of course for large enough p
this becomes negative and the user might
not visit the platform at all
um so with that in mind let's think a
little bit about the platform's question
right this has been a story about what's
going on inside the user
so
let's think about the platform okay now
the problem the platform faces is
obviously sort of enormously complex and
but let's think about just a few of the
ingredients once we have this model in
place right so the platform's trying
aside what content do i put in your feed
right as you're scrolling right and this
is the sense in which
you know yes you're consuming food but
it's in a you know it's in a grocery
store or restaurant or at a reception
where the food is in a sense being you
know sort of assembled and reordered as
you're consuming so
let's imagine that the platform you know
can select content from some feasible
region in pqv space right let's call
this a content manifold right so you
know it could show you
you know
science tutorial videos it could show
you celebrity gossip videos it could
show you you know
music videos it could show you
documentaries about the health etiquette
font it could show you lots of things
right it can wander over the it can't
pick anything from all of pqv space
because some things might just be
infeasible
um but there's some feasible regions
okay
so
it
presents this to the user it then
observes the user's behavior on the
platform including in particular for our
model the session length which we can
think of as again this measure of
engagement
um and for now let's imagine it can't
directly measure user utility yes we'll
come back to the assumption because
there are things like surveys but let's
imagine that
but
even surveys are giving us this
incredibly minimal signal right so let's
we'll think about measuring engagement
and
because it makes the problem sort of
more intriguing and more challenging
let's imagine that you know the platform
ultimately would let's imagine like to
maximize your utility it just has a
communication problem it can't know
your utility it only knows this
engagement
right obviously
it's certainly fine to bring in the idea
that the platform might have bad motives
it might you know sort of want to sort
of just maximize engagement no matter
whether you're happy or not um obviously
that makes the disconnect between
utility engagement even easier to
understand but our point is that even a
platform that is making changes that it
thinks of as well-intentioned is going
to have this challenge
okay
and so the key question is of the
platform form optimizes for engagement
what effect will this have on utility
and
what i want to argue and i'll show you
through some work examples and then sort
of
more general theorem that it's going to
depend on the shape of the manifold in
pqv space
okay in in other words the platform in a
sense has to figure out like does the
optimal content look like chips or does
it look like salad um right if it looks
like chips it should take the bowl away
as soon as it's empty if it looks like
salad it you keep offering new things
until you actually stop
now
for sort of technical reasons we're
going to sort of imagine that this
manifold has some kind of implicit
parameterization right so the platform
can't necessarily say today i'm going to
create a video that has this value of p
this value of q and this value of v bar
those are the kind of
hepa phenomenal properties of the
content
really the platform can vary some
feature vector x which i understand
about the content and then that maps to
a point in the feasible region
and that pre-emphasizes our manifold so
let's make all this concrete right let's
talk about actual
content manifolds and we can work
through some examples that are simple
enough that we can uh
visualize them okay
so maybe the simplest example just to
kind of remind ourselves why we ever
thought engagement was a good idea
maximizing was a good idea in the first
place
imagine a world with no
uh
no system one okay this is just content
that does not appeal system one and so
system two has complete control over
over the user's behavior when they're on
the site
and so
the platform has the ability to modify
the content along a manifold that's
parameterized by some x and basically
this x corresponds to simply making the
content better right so
so p is always zero
q is some base q naught plus x v is some
b v bar some base v naught plus x
so obviously in this situation we go
back to our pair of equations that
govern this and the optimum for both
engagement and utility is to simply
increase x as much as possible all the
way up to its upper bounded epsilon
right engagement goes up utility goes up
and there's just a reminder that this is
why you know in a world where we don't
think about internal conflict where we
don't worry about system one you know
we're faced with a relatively easy or
aligned easier alignment between uh
caveman utility it's actually still not
a perfect alignment i'll come back to
that uh at the end
um
all right second example is sort of a
example of sort of you know
pure trouble right this is sort of the
purest form of what can go wrong
imagine that
the platform is trying to you know
create content for users and discovers
it has this lever it's not quite sure
what the lever does
right but it controls this x and
unbeknownst to the platform it's
basically just making the content more
and more moorish without really changing
its appeal at all to system two it's
just engaging system one more and more
and more
okay
um
and so raising x
well so as i raise x i p is x
and so what's happening to the utility
and the um
the engagement is basically depicted in
this plot here which plots p on the on
the x axis and
orange is the uh the engagement and blue
is the utility so the more i increase um
x
utility
is just going down because system two
gets whatever utility was going to get
but the problem is when it's finally
satiated
there's a period during which you can't
leave because system one is still
engaged and that period is simply
growing monotonically and acts and it's
just burning up utility so this is just
montana in the uvs
um engagement is interesting because
it's going up right why is it going up
well because
i'm just varying this term right and i'm
raising phase two of your time there it
goes up really quite sharply until a
peak
at which point it abruptly
um actually just drops to zero why is
that because that was the moment when
the user's uh
engagement um
the user's utility hit zero
when these utility hits zero they don't
go to the platform at all right they
just know to stay away from it and as a
result you know all that engagement is
gone
and so the platform
if it's not thinking about system one
sees some puzzling behavior right it it
has this lever and it begins moving the
lever
and people are more and more engaged and
this seems great longer and longer
sessions right and so you know when you
meet to review your metrics you're like
this is looking good we're getting
longer you know users are more and more
engaged and then you suddenly find that
you know users who were very very
engaged suddenly just abruptly stop
showing up right and what's happened of
course is that you sort of missed the
fact that you were heading toward this
you were driving the system toward a
cliff and that cliff was where system
two finally sort of rests back control
in this internal conflict and never goes
to the platform
right in the process you've actually
burned up all of the utility in the
system
now
these two examples example one example
two it's never quite this simple right
um and you know when you
obviously you know when you talk to
people who you know work with you know
producing control platforms but like in
particular it's not the simple because
the same things that make us
make system
one crave more tend to make the content
actually more enjoyable right like
there's a these two things are
correlated so
a third example you know is that you
know reality presumably looks sort of
something more like like this
right so
um an example where these problems are
correlated right so again the platform
discovery has this lever and it can vary
the content by moving this lever it
increases the moorishness and it also
increases the quality um just to keep
too much complexity out of this let's
just assume q stays constant although q
is welcome to move also in other
examples right so what's going to happen
here here utility will have an internal
maximum right as you increase
moorishness
utility goes up for a while because the
content is getting better and the
increase in content quality is
temporarily outweighing the loss the
opportunity cost from sort of having to
stay on longer at the end when you sort
of over consume
right um and so it says when we think
about things like regretful use like
let's survey people about you know you
know how much time did you want to spend
how much time did you spend oh that gap
is regretful use we should remember that
for most real situations the correct
amount of regretful use is probably not
zero
because the same aspects of content that
are making you
you know used it regretfully at the very
end are also causing some of the
enjoyment which is why you're going on
the platform in the first place but of
course the problem is if i'm optimizing
for pure engagement i wouldn't know to
stop at this global maximum of utility i
would if i'm only able to measure
engagement keep going again driving
myself toward this cliff where i've
burned off all of the utility right so
this is sort of where what we're
learning is that is engagement a good
signal for utility well it can actually
vary on part of the manifold it's a good
signal and i'm part of the manifold it's
actually a bad signal right and part of
the challenge is to actually uh you know
figure out which is which now we can
create many many more examples just by
mixtures right so if i have you know k
sources i can draw from and i'm like i'm
going to populate your feed by selecting
randomly from these sources
then what i could do is just say okay
i'm going to have mixing weights x1 to
xk where i'm going to have you know
every time i put something into your
feed i'm going to draw from source i
independently with probability x i and
so these are my k features that
you know that are the coordinate system
for the manifold that produce this you
know tuple of pqv and so the result is a
content feed with just this weighted
average of parameters and you know for
example the previous example that we had
um
could be viewed as simply a mixture of
two simple sources right one that's kind
of dull but has no system one problems
where you can leave anytime you want and
one that's you know
supremely addictive um but is higher
quality right and by finding the right
way to mix right so if i mix in too much
of this ingredient i end up with zero
utility and the user knows to stay away
but if i mix in the right amount i can
actually get better utility
and actually this mixture formulation
lets us think about other design choices
right so for example um to sort of
bring up a first sort of example of a
design choice adding breaks right so
we've seen more and more in
including tick tock um
including instagram like
platforms saying we're actually you can
turn something out where it actually
enforces a break like okay time to take
a break right you can
adding breaks you know
intuitively seems like a good idea
because oh good this reminded me i have
to leave behaviorally it's saying it
allows system two to take control and
decide do i still want to be here
and within our model it basically says
we're creating a mixture model in which
we have one more content source with
parameters zero system one's not engaged
some value of q and zero quality like a
break isn't intrinsically interesting
but despite that you can create examples
not unlike the one we saw last where
the the user doesn't want to go on the
platform and then i mix in an amount of
this break genre which has no quality
whatsoever and now the user is willing
to use it and actually gets positive
utility from the system right because
they know that predictably
they'll be able to retake control of
system two and not burn off all the
utility that would have come okay so
actually adding breaks conducive user in
this model as in real life to visit a
platform and they wouldn't have
otherwise okay i see i'm
uh nearing the end of my time um let me
tell you one general result and then
i'll just wrap up with some thoughts and
happy to take happy take more questions
um
so
it's interesting to actually ask can we
characterize the structure of manifolds
where you know engagement optimum is
utility optimum or can we characterize
the subset of a manifold where
engagement is growing monotonically in
utility and all these seem like really
interesting
open questions to us
i'll tell you sort of one general
statement that we're able to make but it
feels like there's much more that's
possible to do here which is let's think
about you know the manifold is some
compact subset of pqv space
um
so it's a subset of this ambient space
um
let's imagine you know for any point
omega which is this triple we have the
expected utility inspecting engagement
let's imagine the point that achieves
the optimal utility the point that she's
the optimal engagement omega s and omega
t s for utility t for engagement
um we have all that and so here's
something at the bottom which is a
general statement that we can say
suppose that
the engagement optim suppose we're in
one of these bad situations right in
which the optimum for engagement omega t
produces strictly higher engagement and
strictly lower utility than the optimum
for utility
okay then in fact that can only happen
for one of two reasons right one of two
things must hold
either
the
moorishness of the engagement optim is
indeed higher than the motion of the
utility optimum as in the platform has
made a mistake by showing content that's
too moorish right that attracts system
one too much
or
if if you actually work out you know the
result you discover that's not the only
reason there's a second reason it could
be that at the engagement option there's
longer span
uh and lower
quality this one was interesting to us
because it's purely a system two
statement right it sort of came out of
the analysis of this and we looked at
this and it actually of course
is something that you also hear about in
online platforms uh even though we sort
of weren't looking to build this in but
it's here it's a statement true about
system two
it says that
the example is search engines sometimes
find that they have accidentally
induced sort of more engagement on the
search engine
because their search results got worse
right if i'm trying to find something on
a search engine
then the ideal experience is that i look
and the first result i want is correct i
click through and i'm gone right so
search is something where i would like
to get
enormous quality
and very short span i won't be gone
immediately
um and if the search results get a bit
worse the user is there for longer but
that's actually worse utility for them
it has nothing to do with system one
it's actually this conjunction of things
it's that now
they're more likely to keep going
because they still need the answer their
question and they're getting lower value
for each step that they take they're
still staying on they're choosing to go
there because the net utility is
positive but
it's it's less than it would have been
had i've been able to greatly increase
the quality and reduce the speed
and so it turns out these are in a sense
the only two reasons within this model
why engagement is a bad proxy for
utility one is because of system one two
aggressively taking over and one is
because of this low quality search
results problem that you spend you you
have spam that's too long but with with
worse quality
okay so this sort of gives the
architecture of this this model that
we've begun sort of thinking about and
experimenting with uh as you can see
there's a a lot more one could possibly
do um i just wanted to wrap up with some
sort of
final
reflections right so this all starts
from the sense that they're you know
platform optimization from behavioral
data is one of the fundamental pillars
of how modern social media works
it's hard to say that it's the wrong
thing to do this is the day they have
and this is sort of what they can infer
but certainly says we need to proceed
carefully right that something is
and in particular proceeding carefully
we're arguing is about
realizing that revealed preference is
not sort of the whole story here right
and so to try explicitly modeling the
inconsistent preferences and thereby at
least telling us something that we can
learn here right and this links to again
as i mentioned a lot of things to you
know
digital addiction to online commitment
devices to this recent line of work on
value alignment for example right trying
to build the values of you know sort of
building systems that imply that the
values of what the user wants to get out
of it um it also provides us a lot of
ways to think about design choices in
the platform and i'll just sort of list
a bunch of ones that we that we've
talked about right how to interpret uh
the day that we collect the fact there's
a conflict the role of surveys um
as a way of getting directly utility the
number of options to display which um i
don't have time in this talk but the
fact that we're working with a linear
content feed but other models we have
include branching
you know this idea that preview versus
autoplay right autoplay is somehow
lowering the cost of system one and
increasing the worstness the benefits of
enforced brakes which adds costs to
system one and therefore uh make system
two get in control more and potentially
makes the platform actually more
enticing despite
nothing happening
and even things that i haven't had a
chance to talk about here but that are
kind of intriguing right even the idea
that system two is in control of the
initial decision to join to go on the
platform right you know i could just
stay away from tick tock completely um
gives you an interesting way to think
about embedded media right so perhaps
you rationally stay away from youtube
because you know you burn too much time
but you do read the washington post and
the problem is the washington post
sometimes ambushes you because midway
through an article they're like this was
nicely captured in this clever youtube
clip check it out and there it is and
just right it just starts playing and
you had wanted to stay away from youtube
but you were reading the washington post
and once it starts playing system one is
in control
right and now system one is just going
and you're burning up utility right and
so in a sense embedded media right
sticking the youtube clip directly in
the article right you know sticking the
embedded tweet directly in the article
and you didn't want to go on twitter is
in a sense and i think you know it's
often not articulate this way but it
it's fun really doing this
it's it's a way of somehow
sort of directly porting system one's
judgment into the situation right and so
my my argument to our argument here is
that you know this is giving us a way of
thinking about a lot of design choices
in terms of this internal conflict you
know we're often seeing surprises i
think
um there's a lot here that's obviously
to be worked out these are very very
simple models for incredibly complicated
situations but our hope is it's giving
at least sort of some additional
vocabulary for talking about something
that has you know over the past 10 years
or so been very very hard to talk about
in any sort of concrete way and so i
think that leads to some interesting
opportunities for discussion going
forward thanks very much
thank you john for the very interesting
talk
questions
yes
thank you john again for the very
uh inspiring talk i say uh i would like
to ask an
open-ended question i would like to
understand a little bit how we can put
in this module a little bit the the
factor of privacy in one sense that uh
and i i think there are two different
ways that i would like to see it
let's say that i am the user and let's
say that i am the platform
if i am the user and the
always in privacy it is where i will put
the trusted the
the trusted barrier so if i am the user
how we can put in the model somehow i i
wouldn't like to to
to inform the model about
my utility but
on the other hand i don't know how
i should not give data to the the system
and
i mean what we can do let's say from the
local dp if i apply it as a user or
from central dp if i apply it uh
as the platform probably
that is one question that i would like
to hear your opinion
yeah thanks it's it's a great question
of course and i you know i won't claim
to have uh the answer to it but
it's something we've yeah we've thought
about i mean so here's a couple of
thoughts so
on the centralized side
um
it's interesting to ask sort of how far
a platform could get with aggregate data
right aggregate of the form that i might
try to you know
apply some principles of differential
privacy or something too and
i say that in the sense that
each user's preferences are of course
idiosyncratic to them but they're
obviously certain
regularities right so you know in the
case of food for example you know
there's there's a reason why i can put
up chips and salad as examples and it at
least hopefully resonates with some of
you in the audience it's because you
know there are certain empirical
regularities in what food you know we
tend to over consume there are certain
empirical regulators and what kind of
media we tend to consume and so the hope
is actually a lot we can make a lot of
progress on this by analyzing data in
aggregate
um where potentially like your presence
or absence in the data is not actually
the
just decisive factor that won't capture
all of the idiosyncratic ways in which
your preferences differ from everyone
else's but it would at least i one would
expect sort of address much of this now
on the
on on the client side right so you as
the user might have as you said like
local information and you can imagine
um
you know app side things
client-side applications where what
you're doing is sort of building some
kind of model of situations where you
tend to over consume where this is kind
of doing some kind of
learning where this is you know this
data is only accessible to you and it's
sort of interesting thing about you know
what can we do looking at your past
behavior or looking at sort of where you
over consume to extend could that become
a kind of predictive guide to sort of
steer away from those situations um
these are two things that we've thought
about one on the kind of centralized
aggregates aside one sort of
local use user-facing side where it can
be their data but i it would be
interesting to think about you know
other opportunities other options for uh
sort of
uh
merging ideas from privacy into this
here i have another question by the way
thanks that was a fascinating talk
um so my question was about how you
elicit p q and v naught
in the real world it seems like a causal
inference kind of
issue where
you don't know whether the person giving
feedback is in system one or system two
so do you have thoughts on that
yeah yeah so we've we've looked a little
bit at some of these so
some things that we've um thought about
in this in this context um
so
so
one is so i mean there's a belief so
first let's talk about
surveys because you know
surveys are interesting things because
there's a belief in in the sort of
uh
world of online platforms that it tends
to be system two that answers surveys
right like system one tends not to
be what you know the part of you that
reflects on your past experience and
evaluates it so they said that we're at
least getting a stronger mixture of
system two in the answers to surveys um
you know you could of course sort of
intervene at certain points and ask you
know are you satisfied right now that
has a couple of things first of all it
actually introduces a break into your
consumption for whatever that's worth
and it also
lists that answer from you um one thing
that we
uh
so there are a couple kinds of surveys
that you might find interesting you know
that might be relevant one is a kind of
regretful use survey right where you ask
someone in advance how long do you ent
are you intending to spend on the
platform and then you measure how long
they did spend on the platform and and
that gap you know you could potentially
say okay that is the period of time
during which system one was in control
which gives us some insight into the
parameters that are governing system two
in this particular genre on this
platform
a second kind of survey is simply a
measure of satisfaction
and one thing that the model suggests
which is quite intriguing is that
the the answer you give to the survey
might actually vary over the course of
your session um and also might vary with
you know the total length of your
session right so if i ask you at the end
of your session what did you think you
know the answer you might give at the
end of a long session might be different
from the answer you give it a at the end
of a short session and it appears that
in
in things that are kind of more
you know continents more like salad
um
your survey answers you would expect to
actually grow increase monotonically
with the length of the session longer
session actually would give higher
survey results and things are more like
potato chips um again at least within
the model you'd expect that actually the
survey results would be worse at the end
of long sessions in short sessions so
another thing that we've been intrigued
by is the possibility that actually
looking at correlations between
uh survey responses as a function of
session
might also give us some some insight
into this
and the third one which i'll just say
briefly is
heterogeneity of participants right so
you know in these pictures we're showing
like you know engagement goes up until
it falls off a cliff but of course each
user has slightly different parameters
each user has even if users had
identical content parameters they'd have
slightly different outside options and
so you'll actually see people begin to
leave gradually and so some other
signals that seem to actually begin
getting at some of these parameters that
are hard to infer are for example the
divergence between
um fraction of users willing to
participate and length of session and
one warning sign is when those two begin
to go in opposite directions so you have
fewer and fewer users on the system for
longer and longer periods of time when
they join
and so i think looking at the divergence
of those also so these are the kinds of
things we're thinking about right taking
various invariants of the system that we
can measure and when there are multiple
of them asking
when they move in different directions
does that tell us something about the
movement of these parameters and in some
cases it seems like there might be some
signal
i have a slightly different kind of
question i think i'm interested in
whether there is uh
any empirical evidence on whether people
choose to engage based on system two
because i don't know in at least my own
mental model i think of people like
hopping on twitter or instagram like
when they're on the bus when they're not
really they're bored it's kind of
habitual right like it's not i don't
necessarily think that it's like a super
calculated
set of decisions and i'm willing to be
wrong about that that's totally a folk
theory yeah yeah no i mean it's a great
question so i mean
we see some you know
some some examples where you know so
what are some of these studies i mean so
studies in which for example i i look at
sort of how much i have to pay you to
give up social media for example and
then look at the
the effects that looking at social media
usage
exactly as you say in situations where
the outside option is higher or lower
right so on the bus is a perfect example
because like your outside option which
is to stare out the bus window seems
very low so you're like okay there's a
genuinely different calculation going on
there um and so people sort of looked at
these as a way of trying to figure out
how much component of planning is going
on in in social media but i think it's
actually to a large extent in
open question you know to what extent
can we map the decision to to to go on
the platform to a pure
system to decision and again my point at
the very end about embedded media also
says that you know the way in which the
content shows up is um
can also be sort of um something which
actually lowers the the the barrier to
you joining right and
in some sense like as we thought about
that example of you know the youtube
clip embedded in the washington post
article um you see analogies that
actually in the food domain right so
um you know it's uh many of us have not
been passing through airports as much as
we used to but if you think back to
passing through an airport you know the
place that sells
the
cinnamon rolls that are high calorie
delicious very system one appealing um
you know you might know to kind of rush
past those because you know if you stop
you might buy one and that would be a
terrible idea but they know to pipe the
smell of the cinnamon roll out into the
concourse right the smell is actually
wafting all around that kiosk that's
selling it because what they're trying
to do is wake up system one right they
want system one to already be eating the
cinnamon roll effectively as you're
walking down the concourse and so that's
another place in which we can sort of
look at the extent to which there's
planning or not in these situations it's
like creating these these these
different situations in which system
might be more or less activated but all
of this is sort of you know a relatively
wide open empirical area to figure out
sort of what are the kind of conditions
under under which we try to get some of
these insights
any more questions
very nice talk oh loud very nice talk
you already touched upon this but i was
wondering if you thought about under
what sort of models could you test like
how far away system one and system two
are from each other so just like based
on you have a number of observations of
how long people have been using the
system and when they drop off you know
when could you under what assumptions
and how many samples would you start to
need to be able to figure out if there
were actually two at play that were very
different
yeah it's a nice question and then i
guess part of it would be is it from
purely observational session length data
do i get other things like survey data
do i get heterogeneity i think all those
are going to affect things you know in
cases where i can sort of ask you
predictive questions how long you hope
to stay
that's perhaps the easiest setting
because then there's almost sort of this
gap that i can try to solve for
um
in cases where there's user
heterogeneity um right it would sort of
the more variation there is in the
population the more i can potentially
get some of these things um but yeah i
think this is
these are sort of interesting so the way
we've thought about would be has been
sort of like what extra information do
we have at our our disposal in the sort
of
pure engagement question i feel like the
question sort of has to be like what
else do i know because if i literally
simply tell you
you you've moved this variable users
spending longer i can't really know have
i increased p or increased q for example
um and so it's off the question like
what else am i combining it with and
that's often with you know something
designed to elicit information like a
survey or something designed to create
divergences between people like
heterogeneity
okay
i think that's it uh let's thank uh john
once again for the very cutting board
thanks very much
you